era una intención manifiesta que el
presidente de los eeuu joe biden
tenía que desmarcarse de su antecesor
con información precisa oportuna y que
permitiera decirle al ciudadano común y
corriente cuáles son las dificultades
que se enfrenta cuáles son las medidas
específicas que se va a tomar y que se
espera lograr al pasar un poco más de
tiempo y las noticias no son buenas en
el sentido de que va a haber más muertos
en el próximo mes porque el invierno y
la temporada así lo demandan y sin duda
alguna después empezará a mejorar a
partir esperar esta administración de
las medidas que se empezaron a tomar de
tipo federal la oposición o el elemento
complejo puede ser a nivel local hay
estados y hay condados en los que la
gente sigue siendo significativamente
reticente a portar máscara en los
lugares públicos y particularmente en
las instituciones federadas que es lo
que dice la orden ejecutivo entonces ahí
con el tiempo se puede crear una
situación en la que el típico
enfrentamiento entre la autoridad
federal y los gobiernos locales de hecho
la administración
en espera para el final de este mes
500.000 personas fallecidas por cuenta
el cob y 19 rafael que significa
entonces que estados unidos regrese a la
ms y también quien se incorpore al fondo
kóvacs
es una medida muy positiva y refleja el
énfasis de esta administración
multilateralismo diplomacia y medidas
que le permitan no sólo a eeuu sino a la
comunidad internacional superar el
problema derivado de la pandemia y otros
que puedan surgir la confianza en un
multilateralismo significa que eeuu
vuelve y al volver eeuu se espera que
disminuye un poco la especulación que
tanto el director general de la
organización mundial de la salud como
otras altas autoridades han señalado es
un problema hay estados que ya tienen
más dosis per cápita de la vacuna de las
que son necesarias y eso está generando
que países de ingresos medios o bajos se
creen se queden perdón sin un número
adecuado de vacunas para sus ciudadanos
es positivo al igual que lo es el
retorno al acuerdo de parís en temas
medioambientales
rafael de piñeros en bogotá en colombia
muchas gracias por este análisis se para
la teleaudiencia de france 24